Please watch the entire video before caring
for your incision.
This video will teach you how to care for
your incision.
An incision is a cut made in your skin during
an operation.
The edges of your incision may be held together
with stitches, staples, skin glue or skin
closure strips.
A bandage called a “dressing” covers your
incision.
To prevent skin infections, keep your dressing
clean and dry.
Taking good care of your incision will help
it heal more quickly.
Caring for your incision involves cleaning
your incision and changing your dressing.
You will need: new bandages, a roll of medical
tape, clean scissors, two pairs of disposable
gloves, two clean, soft cloths or paper towels,
a disposable plastic bag, and a waste basket.
Keep these materials away from your incision
to reduce your risk of infection.
Prepare Materials
Step One: Wash your hands with soap and water
for 30-seconds and then dry them with a clean
towel or paper towels.
Clean hands are the best protection against
spreading infection.
Step Two: Open a new bandage wrapper.
Leave the bandage inside the wrapper and be
careful not to touch it.
Step Three: Cut four pieces of tape and hang
them from the edge of a nearby table or counter.
The pieces of tape should be the same length
as the old ones around your incision.
Remove Old Dressing
Step One: Wash your hands again with soap
and water, and then dry them.
Step Two: Put on disposable gloves.
Step Three: With one hand, press down gently
on the skin next to the old tape around your
incision.
With the other hand, carefully peel away the
old tape toward your incision.
Step Four: After loosening the tape, remove
your old dressing.
Do not remove any skin closure strips covering
your incision.
Let them fall off on their own in about 5
to 10 days.
If your dressing sticks to your incision,
don’t tear it off.
Tearing it off may cause bleeding and delay
healing.
Moisten the dressing with warm water.
Wait for a minute or two until you can easily
remove it.
Look at your old dressing after your remove
it.
If the dressing has a foul or sweet smell
or it has yellow or greenish stain, call your
healthcare provider.
Step Five: Place the old dressing in a disposable
plastic bag.
Step Six: Remove the disposable gloves.
Throw the gloves and the plastic bag containing
your old dressing in the waste basket.
Clean the Incision
Clean your incision only if your healthcare
provider says you should.
Your healthcare provider may only want you
change your dressing.
Make sure you understand what your healthcare
provider wants you to do, and be sure to call
with questions or concerns.
Step One: Wash your hands with soap and water
and dry them.
Step Two: Put on a new pair of disposable
gloves.
Step Three: Always use a clean cloth, warm
water, and if your healthcare provider says
you can, a mild antibacterial soap.
To gently remove dried material from the area
around your incision, start with the areas
nearest your incision and wipe outwards or
away from the incision.
Use a different part of the cloth each time
you wipe your skin.
When the cloth is dirty, use a new, clean
cloth.
Do not scrub or remove any scabs.
Scabs protect your incision while it heals.
Allow them to fall off on their own.
Do not wipe or rub over stitches, staples,
or skin closure strips.
Unless your healthcare provider says you should,
do not clean your incision with alcohol, iodine,
or peroxide.
Step Four: Let your incision air dry.
As it dries, check your incision for the following:
stitches or staples that are out of place,
the edges of your incision pulling open, bleeding
around your incision, redness that extends
more than one inch from your incision edges,
increased skin warmth around your incision,
swelling around your incision, foul or sweet
smelling incision odor, or a white, yellow,
or green discharge coming from your incision.
Call your healthcare provider if you notice
any of these changes.
Unless your healthcare provider says you should,
do not use ointment, lotion, or powder on
your incision.
Step Five: Remove your disposable gloves and
throw them in the waste basket.
Apply New Dressing
Step One: Wash your hands with soap and water
and dry them.
Step Two: Put on a new pair of disposable
gloves.
Step Three: Pick up a piece of gauze by one
corner.
Do not touch the side that will be next to
your incision.
Carefully cover your incision with the gauze
pad.
You may need more than one gauze pad if fluid
is still coming out of your incision.
Hold the gauze pad in place with one hand
and tape the gauze pad to your skin with the
other hand.
Make sure you seal all four edges of the dressing.
If your skin is red from the tape on your
old dressing, put the new tape on a different
part of your skin.
If your skin is swollen or has blisters, contact
your healthcare provider.
You may be allergic to the tape and need to
try a different kind.
Step Five: Remove your gloves and put them
into the waste basket.
Step Six: Wash your hands again with soap
and water and dry them.
It’s normal to see mild redness and swelling
around your incision edges or a clear or pinkish
discharge; however, you should contact your
healthcare provider if you notice any white,
yellow, or green discharge coming from your
incision, a foul or sweet incision odor, the
shape of your incision changes, redness that
extends more than one inch from your incision
edges, increased warmth of the incision, and
bleeding or swelling around your incision.
Also, call your healthcare provider if you
have nausea, vomiting, diarrhea, or a temperature
of 101-degrees Fahrenheit or higher.